[Music]
this is your three-minute bootcamp core
workout alright guys so we've got a core
workout here with my man Noah
representing bootcamp now okay we talked
about core a lot yes we know what that
is this corset should work out some
people don't
people think cores abs core is a whole
lot of different things beliefs we have
everything that's really to protect your
spine and keep you upright that's cool
so core let's just start it up let's go
it's better to show you I'm a visual
person so we're gonna hit a plank
position we're gonna jump our feet in
making sure we exhale and contract our
abs and then jump those feet out okay so
you've done a plank before let's take it
up a notch so plank checking what we're
gonna do we're gonna take it to a
Superman position to work our lower back
very important as we up our ab work we
focus and protect our lower back as well
because our halves are gonna pull on
that back so we're gonna hit a Superman
we're gonna hit five repetitions and
we're gonna bring it up into open
push-up we'll hit that six times okay so
then we'll head on to the last move
we're gonna do a full body move focus on
that core so bring it up hands walk it
out when we get to an outreach position
we raise it up connect raise it up
connect so we're gonna start using some
stabilizer muscles because when we're up
like this a lot of different things have
to fire to keep us upright walk it back
out one repetition we'll hit that for a
minute
so everything's gonna be done in a
minute but like I said the only time you
have to count is when we do those
Superman raises
okay let's give it a shot all right so
let's start it up I'm gonna put you in
plank position first a plank position
you've you've heard it a lot
not many people do this properly so what
you're gonna do is this I'm gonna come
down with you we're gonna make sure that
our elbows are right under those
shoulders
we're gonna let our chest drop down into
that shoulder of cavity we're gonna make
sure we keep our butt up though in
alignment with our shoulders and back
okay keeping it nice and tight drawing
from our midsection to really keep us
upright okay now that you have the
basics down jump it in jump those feet
out and jump it right back in one minute
so let's give it a go let's not talk
about it let's be about it right now be
about it come on jump those feet in now
sprawl there explode so what I want you
to do is really fight gravity with your
abs instead of your legs perfect elbows
are staying right under those shoulders
keeping a tight exhaling on the in and
out and we'll go on to the next move one
minute right now go get it perfect on
what you're really focused on flexing
and raising through that back back of
the heels are coming straight up back of
the palms are coming straight up after
the six one elbows are gonna be right
under those risks risks are right under
their shoulders you're a pillar of
strength right there flex and squeeze
perfect II you got that exhale perfect
okay what's up guys all right so we just
came out of that move we're gonna squat
our hands down walk it out to that
outstretched position holding that
standing plank reach connect that knee
reach elbow knee then walk it back there
you go let's hit it
finish this minute strong right here up
there you go feel that strength coming
from your midsection all in that
stabilization is firing through your
core and one more bring it back bring it
back bring it back on time that's it
okay
okay so to recap start off with a plank
into a sprawl you do a minute of that
then you go into the Superman a plank
kick out a minute of that let me go into
the hand walk out cross body raise we do
a minute of those three minutes that's
your core workout boot camp-style
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes
[Music]